hey guys I want to talk about quick
about the David I Brian rose London real
situation their interview just got a
taken off YouTube and from YouTube and I
want to give my take on it my channel
has obviously fought battles of free
speech in the past not with YouTube but
with private individuals over what I
could say what I couldn't say so I have
a strong opinion on this matter I
thought I'd give it to you guys first
before I make a separate video where I
basically explain why I think the David
Icke London real interview was an
absolute garbage fest of misinformation
and dangerous ideas that were totally
left unchallenged by Brian Ross is there
a virus there is no kovat 19 it doesn't
exist so I think the interview was a
complete failure but YouTube's reaction
to shutting it down I have a totally
different take on and I think it
distracts from how bad the interview was
and how stupid the interview was because
this freeze it's now become a free
speech issue right because it's been
censored censored yeah it's been
censored they don't want you to learn on
the trip and my take on this is that
YouTube shouldn't have done it YouTube
for two reasons for one for pragmatic
reasons two philosophical reasons I
disagree with it but I understand you to
spur spective and I think a lot of
people are missing YouTube's perspective
on the whole thing they don't understand
hey why is YouTube suddenly banning this
guy all they hear is about the banning
and they don't know the wider context of
this situation
so let me give you that wider context
real quick so the reason YouTube
specifically taking down videos that try
to link 5 g and coronavirus the reason
for that the real reason is that there
were arson attacks in Britain of 5g
towers by people who believed that there
was a link here so right so some
conspiracy theorists of whom David Icke
is one of them were promoting this idea
that 5g was causing the corona virus and
then people who heard that and believed
it said oh well let me go stop 5g right
because if 5 G's hurting all these
people I'm gonna stop 5g and try to help
people and so they set fire to these
towers which is a huge problem you can't
have your society committing
arson attacks based on crackpot theories
and so somewhat understandably YouTube
is trying to find a way to limit their
own liability they're like we don't want
to be the cause of the spread of these
crazy ideas okay
that's their perspective I think a lot
of people didn't know that real world
violent actions were taken in the real
world now to my knowledge no one was
hurt but people could have been let's be
clear when you set fire to something you
don't know whether someone's gonna be
hurt or not so real lives have been
impacted by the words of these
conspiracy theorists okay so that's
number one because free speech applies
up until it violates someone else's
rights so there is a bit of a question
mark of you know when you're promoting
ideas that cause real-world of its to
take place that could harm people does
your free speech still apply that's a
philosophical question because obviously
David Icke is not telling his followers
to go burn 5g towers although he's sort
of dances around the topic he says he
doesn't want violence to be committed
against people you know I am personally
absolutely anti violence against people
but he also says you know make of this
what you will 5g will in the world and
if 5g continues and reaches where they
want to take it human life as we'd known
it he's over so what people decide to do
about that ISM he's up to them so
there's a question of how much he
promotes it but but but I think it is on
the edge I mean I think anyone could see
went with this context that this is on
the edge of speech but my personal take
is that YouTube censoring London real
censoring David Icke is going to cause
more problems than it fixes because like
I said it turns this into a free speech
issue which really this should be an
issue of mocking this nutjob
for his crazy ideas instead it becomes
oh you the big the big man is trying to
censor David Icke so I think tactically
from YouTube's own like reasoning on it
where they don't want this conspiracy
spreading them more people this is
failing our
censorship usually does fail because the
Barbara Streisand effect people most
people know it if you try to shut
something down people think that there
must be some truth of it and they want
to watch it more so I think YouTube's
attempts failed they're just
pragmatically but also philosophically
you have to deal with the fact that when
you allow free speech when you if you
believe in free speech I mean you you
may not agree with me on this
on this topic doing the work that I do I
have a pretty strong sense of free
speech so so I think that unless people
like David Icke are outright saying go
commit acts of violence go do these
things they're largely protected I mean
it just is what it is philosophically I
think they should be allowed to say what
they say and I also am of the belief
that places like YouTube they don't
really have a valid competitor in the
market they are kind of a marketplace of
an idea of ideas I kind of think
YouTube's a public utility
so even though it is a private company
most people say the private company has
the right to do whatever it wants it can
censor whoever it wants I think your
platform like YouTube you've owned a
monopoly and when you have a monopoly
and you're providing video sharing which
is basically I would argue a public
utility in today's society
I don't think YouTube should have the
right to be like oh yeah we just don't
like you we don't like what you're
saying and be able to shut them down on
that unless you can really draw a link
between violence and the person and a
clear link I think I think if you're
like me if you believe that people
should have free speech you have to
accept the fact that some of the people
with free speech are crazy and they're
gonna say some crazy stuff and some
people in society are dumb and they're
gonna believe that crazy dumb stuff so I
think that's just a something that I I'm
coming to grips with I mean I just
accept that it's a fact of life people
like David Icke exist and people exist
that will believe what David Icke says
so so yeah I just don't think censorship
was the right right thing here
tactically from YouTube's own agenda
like of not wanting more people to
commit harm and believe this crazy
conspiracy and also philosophically I
just disagree with
that thing I think David Ickes comments
do follow to free speech even though
it's crazy and insane and he's an idiot
right but it is very much on the edge
and I accept that some of you out there
will disagree with me and that's okay
you can disagree with me because it like
I said it is that edge case you know III
don't think you're crazy if you think
that his comments fall more on that line
of shouting fire in a theater and that
free speech doesn't apply I see where
you're coming from but that's what I
wanted to say on that issue now I really
wanted to talk about the actual content
of the interview which has been totally
hijacked by this free speech
conversation so I'm gonna make a
separate video about that I had to
really I feel like these are two issues
totally separate what David Icke
actually said on Bryan Rose's interview
on the London real interview and this
free speech question so that's the free
speech part and I'll see you in the next
video for the actual insanity that
ensued from this interview
[Music]
[Music]